foreign
he's the man whose case spawned a wave
of True Crime as entertainment now Adnan
Syed is leading prison his conviction
quashed the 41 year old has spent 23
years behind bars for the murder of his
ex-girlfriend hymin Lee but prosecutors
say a new investigation has pinpointed
two other suspects Syed supporters are
delighted I spent 20 years with Adnan uh
he's a very good friend of mine I love
him to death it was like a weight lifted
off my shoulders to see him released and
freed today knowing that he was innocent
the whole time he's an impeccable human
being um
is a wonderful person and hopefully the
world to get to see that real soon
the hit podcast serial breathed new life
into science defense nine years ago it
cast out on his conviction transformed
the True Crime genre and changed how
many viewed the justice system Chicago
it's cereal one story told week by week
I'm Sarah Koenig 18 year old high Min
Lee's body was found discarded in a park
her family say they were blindsided by
the decision to quash sayad's conviction
my clients all they wanted was
information they want the truth to come
out if the truth is that someone else
killed their sister daughter they want
to know that more than anybody they were
shut out of the legal process by the
court and the State's Attorney's office
and there was it was inexcusable the
violation of Maryland law and our my
clients are exploring their options with
regard to appeal
society's now under house arrest he's
not yet been declared innocent
prosecutors have 30 days to decide
whether to retry him their next step and
his will once again be firmly in the
media glare after calner Sky News